elles sont en direct bonjour
moi je mets toi je ne dois je nettoie
porte quoi je suis la tornade blanche
quand je me retrousse les manches et de
tout du sol au plafond moi je fais le
ménage à fond
moi je nettoie je tais toi j'étais toi
n'importe quoi je suis là fort nargue
ans je meurs tous ses lancers
le ménage à fond
ces pirates
et
la grâce il n'a pas fait la guerre à la
poussière celle où la moindre tache sur
mon là c'est mon dernier on commence par
là
quinzaine hier où les carreaux à cette
tâche mais je considère la salle et non
pas au micro les subsides bombasse émis
sans attaquer plus chassaigne là
j'attends que mon appart jacques
s'épuise en bandoulière
moi je nettoie et je ne mets toi je
nettoie n'importe quoi je suis la
tornade blanche jay perdre tout ce que
j'ai de tout du sol au plafond
d'égal à égal à moi et j'étais toi et je
nettoie et je nettoie n'importe quoi je
suis la tornade blanche sans je me
retrousse ses manches et de toute sa
classe pour le japon
je lance à la recherche samedi à
s'oublier et je vais la pêche est
vraiment top et je mets tout demandeur
m toutefois ces mois ci past 10h50
jacquard ce
oui je ne tarit pas d'injures jamais de
s'amuser seul aux chaussures par an tout
juste le fait je me sens renaître ou
ciel n'est pas m'as pas changé je le
sens du de guerrière vineuil albert ier
je ne dois je nettoie et je nettoie
n'importe quoi je suis la tornade
blanche je me retrousse les manches de
tout du sol
m
je nettoie je nettoie et je nettoie
n'importe quoi je suis la corne a de la
chance je me retrouve seul angers de
tous
je fais le ménage à fond de
moi je nettoie et jamais toi et je
nettoie n'importe quoi je suis la
tornade blanche je me retrousse ses
manches et ou du sol au plafond
je l'avais la faune des gardiens
me